TO CALL THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IT.
MINISTER TO REVIEW HEARING TO
ORDER AT THIS POINT.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM THAT
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF AUTHORS
HERE SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
OKAY I'M AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
START WITH MR COOLEY
[inaudible]
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES -- IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE WITH YOU TO PRESENT AB.
THREE TWELVE AND I VIEW THIS
BILL AS IT'S ACTUALLY SORT OF
THING THAT I THINK MOST OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WOULD LIKE US TO DO
GENERALLY. TO ENCOURAGE THAT WE
REMAIN A A STATE.
OF LAW GOVERNED BY LAW.
AND THAT SOMEBODY IS PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE CURRENT
APPLICABILITY OF THAT LAW. TO
ENSURE THAT IF THERE'S YOU KNOW
OUR BASIC SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT
AS WE ADOPT STATUTES.
WE CAN FOR AUTHORITY TO AGENCIES
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS AND THEY
HAVE DONE THAT THERE'S PROBABLY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THOUSAND PAGES
OF REGULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS.
THAT ALL AGENCIES A STATE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR REGULATIONS. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE STILL.
UP [inaudible]
CURRENT.
NOT CONFLICT WITH OTHER BODIES
OF LAW.
REMAIN AFTER THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE.
IT'S REALLY DESIGNED TO MAKE
SURE OUR LAW IS A LIVING THING
NOT A DEAD THING AND THAT THE
RULES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
GUIDING.
OUR ECONOMY OUR CURRENT -- I GO
IN THIS BACKGROUND A LITTLE BIT
I ACTUALLY DO THINK THAT THIS
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY SOUND GOOD
GOVERNMENT IT IS AN IDEA THE
REPEAL OF MOST CALIFORNIANS.
ARM.
FROM A VERY PERSONAL STANDPOINT
MY WIFE WHO WORKS AS A CHURCH
BOOKKEEPER.
HAD AN AGENCY OF STATE
GOVERNMENT THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION SEND THE LETTER
TELLING THEM THAT THEY HAD TO
REDO THEIR CHURCH BYLAWS. TO
CONFORM BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
RULES.
AND MY WIFE JUST BECAUSE OF OUR
CONGREGATION WADE WE DO THESE
RULES IS CUMBERSOME.
CHECK CAN YOU DOCUMENT FOR ME
WHY THIS IS REQUIRED.
THIS LED TO A TWO YEAR LONG
HIATUS.
AS A USER INTERNAL COUNSEL
OUTSIDE COUNSEL CAME BACK AND
SAID WELL ACTUALLY WE'VE BEEN
ASKING PEOPLE THAT FOR YEARS WE
HAVE NO AUTHORITY.
FOR SO THIS IDEA THAT WE ARE A
NATION OF LAWS A STATE OF LAWS
KEEP THE LAWS CURRENT KEEP THEM
TIED THIS STATUTE.
IT'S WHAT'S BEHIND THIS BILL IT
WOULD REQUIRE A ONE TIME GOING
TO THOROUGHLY.
IT WOULD INCLUDE A PUBLIC
HEARING SO PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE
CANDIDATES REGULATIONS AT THE
THE QUESTION.
THEY COULD SAY THAT IN A PUBLIC
HEARING AND TRY TO GET IT IN THE
QUEUE FOR EXAMINATION.
THE OTHER THING TO KNOW ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
IS THAT IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN DARRYL
STEINBERG WAS TO PRO TIM IN THE
SENATE.
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS CONDUCTED
THEIR POLICY RETREAT IN FEBRUARY
OF THAT YEAR.
AND CAME AWAY AND THIS WAS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS AND TWENTY
ELEVEN FOR VARIETY REASONS THAT
YOU'RE DO WITH THE BUDGET THE
IDEA DID DOCKET ADOPTED SO I'VE
KIND OF KEPT MOVING FORWARD.
SO -- ANYWAY THAT'S THE BACK
DROP ON THIS THE IT WOULD
REQUIRE AS I SAY THIS REVIEW TO
BE CONDUCTED.
I THINK IT IS GOOD GOVERNMENT I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING REPEAL
EVERYONE AS SOUND.
I ALSO FEEL.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE QUESTIONS NOW
WHERE THE ECONOMY'S GOING WELL
WE SOMEDAY HAVE RECESSION WHAT
WILL HAPPEN.
WE WE HAVE SENIORS THAT NEED TO
GET THE WORK FORCE THEY NEED
JOBS ARE AVAILABLE HAVE YOUNG
COLLEGE GRADUATES NEED TO GET
THE WORK FORCE.
THEY NEED JOBS AVAILABLE.
ARE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
REGULATORY SYSTEM IS WELL
ADAPTED TO THAT NEED AND AND
TIED BOTH THE LAW AND NOT IN
CONFLICT.
REALLY SUPPORTS THAT ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT ALL THESE PEOPLE
SEEKING JOBS RELY UPON.
SO I FEEL THIS IS A ONE SMALL
STEP THAT ACTUALLY IS.
IS VERY SIGNIFICANT I HAVE WITH
ME A REPRESENT OF THE STATE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
PAUL ASKED ROBERT MUTRIE TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU.
JUST TO BE CLEAR COULD TO MUTUAL
ROBERT MUTRIE FOR THE CAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE
VIEW IT AS A SINCERE SPRING
CLEANING THAT'S BEEN TWENTY
YEARS DELAYED RIGHT AND WHEN YOU
DON'T CLEAN IT OUT.
BECAUSE ITGETS MESSY THERE'S
THINGS IN THERE YOU DON'T WANT
ANYMORE AND IT'S HARD TO USE.
AT A BASIC LEVEL WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HOPES FOR IS
THAT THROUGH MEASURES LIKE THIS.
THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT GETS
TO BE SOMETHING THAT IS --
EASIER TO WORK THROUGH YOU KNOW
THE IT HAS TO BE THERE OF COURSE
BUT WE NEED SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN WORK THROUGH CLEANLY -- AND
ONE POINT WHICH I'D LIKE TO ADD
AS THEY BELIEVE THIS WILL ALSO
BE GOOD FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID THIS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND SUBSEQUENT ANALYSIS SHOWED
THAT IT SAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- THIRTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS SO I I THINK
THIS IS A WIN WIN ON ALL SIDES
REALLY -- FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND THE STATE AND SO
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A QUORUM SO.
YES WE DO NOW HAVE A QUORUM.
AT THIRTY LIKE TO TAKE THE ROLE
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
LACKING.
MEDINA.
MEDINA PRESENT QUIRK SILVA.
X. OF A PRESENCE SMITH.
SMITH PRESIDENT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I'M MISTER COOLEY TO HAVE AT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NOT SURE THE REFERENCES IN AND
MARK IN THE RANKS TODAY SCENE
NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION -- WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- AWHILE
WHEN ITS BASE IT SOUNDS
REASONABLE WE BELIEVE THAT --
THIS BILL WOULD DIVERT LIMITED
RESOURCES FROM STATE AGENCIES
FROM PERFORMING THEIR CORE
MISSION TO WORK THAT THE OIL IS
ALREADY DOING -- THE OILS RT
TASKED WITH REVIEWING A NEW RACE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE --
NECESSARY CLEARED NINE
DUPLICATIVE AND LEGALLY VALID
THEY WORK IN COORDINATION WITH
THE STATE AGENCIES TO TO
IMPLEMENT THESE NEW RAKE SO
AGAINST REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES
TO REDO THIS WORK OR TO
DUPLICATE THOSE EFFORTS THAT ARE
ALREADY BEING DONE -- IT'S
UNNECESSARY SO FOR INSTANCE YOU
HAVE THE LABOR AGENCY INSTEAD OF
ENFORCING ISSUES LIKE WAGE
THEREFORE WORKER SAFETY
PROTECTIONS OR WORKPLACE
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS WERE -- OUR
FOR OUR VULNERABLE WORKERS
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE STAFF
MONEY AND RESOURCES TO DO THE
WORK AGAIN AT THE YELLS ARGUMENT
HAS TO DO -- AND I WOULD ALSO
ADD THAT IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT PRESENTLY TO GET
REGULATIONS PASSED THERE'S A
ROBUST A QUARTER PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES -- EMPLOYERS THAT
INCLUDES WORKERS THAT INCLUDES
ADVOCATES THAT INCLUDES THE
COMMUNITY AND THE REGULATORS IN
ORDER TO INSURE THAT THESE
REGULATIONS ARE -- ARE
APPROPRIATE NECESSARY AND AND
PASSED IN A QUICK MANNER BUT
IT'S NOT QUICK IT'S DIFFICULT
AND ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
ARGUMENT THAT YOU HEAR FROM.
BUSINESSES WITH A YEAR FROM
EMPLOYERS BUT WE TRY AND PASS
NEW PARTICULAR WORKER SAFETY
REGULATIONS IS THAT THE REAGAN
UNNECESSARY -- SO WE PASS -- HE
STAND INDOOR HE STANDARDS OR
OTHER ISSUE THAT THE WORKPLACE
THE NUMBER ONE ARGUMENT IS THAT
THESE BAGS ARE UNNECESSARY SO
IT'S A REQUIRE -- SIR TO ROUTE
IT'S REQUIRED IT'S IT'S TO SET
UP A SCENARIO WHERE YOU HAVE TO
RE LITIGATE THIS ISSUE OR RE
ARGUE THIS ISSUE FOR EVERY
SINGLE WORKER SAFETY RAY HAVE TO
RE PROVE.
THAT REGULATION IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE OF A SERIOUS HARM TO
WORKER SAFETY A SO AGAIN BECAUSE
THE OIL DOES THIS WORK IN
BECAUSE IT'S SO STREAMY WITH TO
GIVE YOU DIRECT PATH ALREADY --
AND THE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO
WORKERS ANSWER CONSUMERS INTO
THE PUBLIC WE ARE OPPOSED.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CURRENT PLAYING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE --
WE'RE ALIGNED HERE WITH OUR
OPPOSITION -- WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR THREE PRIMARY REASONS
SAME REASONS HERE FIRST EXISTING
LAW ARE YOU ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
THROUGH -- A. L. AS JUST MEANT
MICHAEL JUST MENTIONED HERE --
REVIEWED THE YET -- A. L.
REVIEWS PROPOSED REGULATIONS FOR
NECESSITY AUTHORITY.
CLARITY CONSISTENCY REFERENCE
AND NON DUPLICATION SO IT'S
ALREADY HAPPENING SECONDLY WE
CONTEND THAT REGULATIONS ARE
PROTECTIONS.
WHICH SAFEGUARD HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF WORKERS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
LASTLY UNDER AB THREE TWELVE
AGENCIES WILL SPEND TIME AND
RESOURCES ON A DUPLICATIVE.
OF BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS INSTEAD
OF PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS --
ACCORDINGLY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON A. B..
THREE TWELVE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MATT BROUGHT HERE ON
BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS IN
OPPOSITION THEY GIVE.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MEDINA.
MISSION TO THE AUTHOR -- MR
COOLEY THE THE THE BILL'S INTENT
AND WHAT IT DOES.
IS TO LOOK AT A DUPLICATIVE
REGULATIONS AND AND AND AND AND
IT IT WOULDN'T BE AN ATTEMPT --
TO HAVE TO ARGUE.
THE EXISTING REGULATIONS EXACTLY
I ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT MY LABOR COLLEAGUES
THEY'RE WRONG ON THE LAW.
THEY HAVEN'T ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
EVEN THE SIZE OF THE OIL AGENCY
IN ITS MISSION.
ALWAYS A L. EXIST TO REVIEW NEW
REGULATIONS.
THEY DO NOT.
RUN A NET ON EXISTING
REGULATIONS FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS OUT THAT IS NOT IN
THE MISSION OF OIL THERE'S NO
ASPECT A LOYAL THE TOUCHES.
THIS PIECE NOR DOES THIS BILL
AND I THINK IF YOUR QUESTION.
ADDRESS ANY REQUIREMENT
[inaudible] TO ARTICULATE A NEW
JUSTIFICATION FOR EXISTING RAGS
ALREADY IN PLACE FURTHER IN A
PUBLIC PURPOSE IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC DUPLICATIVE OVERLAPPING.
INCONSISTENT -- OUT OF DATE.
SO YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
SOMETHING HAS CHANGED.
IN THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
REGULATION OPERATES.
THAT CAUSES A A QUESTION WHETHER
THE WHETHER THIS RAG REMAINS
CURRENT FOR THE PRESIDENT
ENVIRONMENT.
SO I A IT IS IT IS A FANTASY TO
SUGGEST THAT AWAY AL IS DOING
THIS WORK.
REALLY WHAT YOU HAVE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND NOT JUST DATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN A GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCY.
IS THE NEAREST THING YOU HAVE TO
A PERPETUAL MOTION MACHINE.
YOU PASSED THE LAW.
THEIR DOCTOR RAG AND THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THAT.
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE KINDA RE
EXAMINE SINGS OR PROP TO RE
EXAMINATION WHICH IS OUR
FUNCTION -- IT IS OF COURSE YOU
KNOW THE MODEL WITH OUR CHAMBERS
IN.
GOLD LEAF IN THE CHAMBERS IS DO
THE LEGISLATURE. TO PASS JUST
LOS.
IN THE SENATE CHECK THE LIBERTY
OF ITS CITIZENS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A JUST LAW
LIBERTY THE SERVICE AND THE LAWS
BUT FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
AND NOT UNDULY RESTRAINING LIFE --
SO I THINK.
IT IS A ONE TIME MATTER.
AND HONESTLY I THINK.
WE OUGHT TO HAVE.
WE OUGHT TO STAND UP IS
LAWMAKERS. FOR A WELL FOUNDED
STATE GOVERNMENT.
THAT WARRANTS THE EX THE EX
RESPECT THAT WE BELIEVE WE
SHOULD HAVE.
AND I THINK THAT'S OUR JOB IS
LAWMAKERS IT'S OUR FUNCTION THE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT IT'S WHY WE
ENGAGE IN OVERSIGHT -- SO THAT I
I I'VE HEARD THE ARGUMENT BUT IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE A NEW RATIONALE
FOR THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND PAGES
OF REGULATIONS WHICH PRESENTLY
EXISTING CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
I IT'S QUITE -- FOR YOU ANSWER
PART OF THE QUESTION BY MISTER
BIDDING IS QUESTION BUT ON THE
NEW REGULATIONS THAT ARE FORMED
WITH -- AWAY EL DO YOU KNOW THAT.
IF THEY ARE MONITORING IF THE
REGULATIONS ARE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED AT ALL SO -- WE PASS.
TELL A LAW WE HAVE A TIME. FOR
IT TO BE IMPLEMENTED AND ARE
THEY ACTUALLY MONITORING DO THEY
GET IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT WAS ONE OF THE DISCUSSIONS
WE HAD HERE LAST YEAR ON
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IS HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THE LAW
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW THE THE OIL LAW WAS
AUTHORED BY SPEAKER LEO MCCARTHY
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE SIGNED BY
JERRY BROWN IT IS AUTHORITY
BASED.
IT'S AN EXAMINATION OF IS THE
PROPOSED REGULATION FOUNDED UPON
THE AUTHORIZES STATUTES THEY
HAVE THE SEVEN LEGAL CRITERIA
THEY APPLY TO EVALUATE
REGULATIONS.
BUT NO THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT
THE ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION
THAT'S NOT THEIR JOB.
IT'S LIKE IS IT IS IT JUST FIVE
WITHIN THE FOUR CORNERS A
STATUTE IS A SUPPORTED.
ARE ON SOME LEVEL BASED UPON THE
TIME OF THE THEIR EXAMINE IT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IS IT.
EFFECTIVELY DRAFTED DISAPPEAR
THIS GOING TO WORK SO THERE IS
CERTAINLY A ATTENTION TO ITS
EFFECT IN THE REAL WORLD WOULD
YOU OR YOUR BILL WORK ON THAT
PART OR JEFF I WOULD SAY THAT
THE THE ONGOING WORK I'VE DONE
ON THE SUPPORTING OVERSIGHT
PEARL THE STANDING COMMITTEES
THE BODY.
WE HAVE THE OVERSIGHT GUIDE
THAT'S OUT THERE ARE STANDING
COMMITTEES ARE ENCOURAGED TO
OVERSIGHT.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S ACTUALLY THE
ONGOING WORK THE LEGISLATURE
GAUGING OVERSIGHT.
WHAT STRUCK TO EVERY AGENCY?
OF THAT -- YOU KNOW WE WE SEE IT
HAPPEN IN OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE.
I GIVE A CREDIT TO MISTER TING
AND HIS COLLEAGUES IN THE OTHER
HOUSE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE DOES THIS WORK
THIS COMMITTEE OF COURSE PLAYS A
VERY KEY ROLE OVERSIGHT.
SOMEWHAT UNIQUE TO THE OTHER
STANDING COMMITTEES BECAUSE THE
TASK OF THIS.
BOARD AND EACH SUBJECT MATTER.
THE WHOLE PREMISE OF OVERSIGHT
IS THAT WE HAVE OUR THIRTY ONE
STANDING COMMITTEES.
ALL OF WHOM.
WE HAVE WE ARE DEVELOPING
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT STAFF
SUBJECT BY SUBJECT BY SUBJECT.
AND THAT'S STAFF IS TASKED WITH
REVIEWING NEW BILLS.
BUT ALSO KEEPING AN EYE ON HOW
EXIST TO DOLLARS BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
SORT OF A COMES THEIR ATTENTION
THAT MAY BE THE LEAD TO TRY TO
TAKE A PEEK AT SOMETHING -- THEY
CAN DO THAT SO I'D SAY THE
ONGOING FUNCTION OVERSIGHT.
IS REALLY.
IN THE LEGISLATURE -- SO THIS
BILL ACTUALLY IS NOT DESIGNED TO
YES SIR TO GET INTO THAT.
IT'S MORE A SNAPSHOT IN TIME.
LOOKING AT PRUNING [inaudible]
IF APPROPRIATE.
PAUL JUST FOLLOW UP WHICH I DO
APPRECIATE THE BILL I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS.
BUT AS WAS NOTED.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
THAT HAVE CHANGED OVER TIME SO
IF WE JUST USE TECHNOLOGY AS ONE
ON ON OUR BOOKS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT A DECADE TWO
DECADES AGO?
THERE THERE'S MANY THINGS THAT
WE WERE DOING THEN THAT WERE
PROBABLY NOT EVEN LOOKINGAT NOW
ALSO CLEANING UP AS YOU MIGHT
SAY AS A METAPHOR.
I THINK -- DEFINITELY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ONLY DID DO
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND DIVE MISTER
PATTERSON.
I'M SCHOOL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD -- OF
I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY --
BUT JUST A LITTLE INDICATION OF
HOW DEEP AND WIDE -- THAT THE
PROBLEM REALLY IS -- THERE'S AN
AREA THAT I'VE BEEN PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN WHICH IS TITLED
TWENTY TWO AND HEALTH CODE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SOMETHING IT
WAS PASSED NINETEEN SEVENTY IT
WAS LAST MODERNIZED.
AND IF YOU TALK TO HOSPITALS
CLINICS DOCTORS IT'S AFTER.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE TITLE
TWENTY TWO IS SO OUTDATED.
AND IF YOU TALK TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF TITLE.
TWENTY TWO TODAY THEY WILL SAY
IT IS IN FACT OUT DATED TO WHAT
DEGREE.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN THE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE AN ACTION.
THAT IS SO OUTDATED THAT THE
ONLY THING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN DO AND THE ONLY THING THAT
THE HOSPITAL OR IS TO SAY.
WE REQUEST A WAIVER.
GO CHECK HOW MANY WAIVERS ARE
GIVEN OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
SO THAT THE THE REGULATION IS
ESSENTIALLY SO OUTDATED AS TO BE
IRRELEVANT TO THE PRESENT.
TIME -- AND SO I THINK THAT IF
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
DUPLICATIVE IF WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT REGULATIONS -- THAT BORE
WANT MAYBE ONCE SERVED A PURPOSE
BUT SIMPLY.
ARE SO OUTDATED -- SO I I
APPRECIATE THE WORK AS AS FAR AS
IT DOES GO BUT I DO THINK WE
THIS THIS COMMITTEE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT SO MANY OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE SO OUTDATED
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO GET WAVE
AFTER WAVE AFTER WAVE.
FOR WHICH BASICALLY SAYS PRIME
APHASIA THAT THE REGULATION IS
SO OUTDATED IT TO BE MEANINGLESS
AND YET THE HOSPITALS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
ASKING FOR THE WAIVER.
UP THE SPENDING STAFF TIME ON IT
OFTENTIMES HAVING TO HAVE
PROFESSIONALS RIGHT THE WAIVER
LANGUAGE.
AND THE WAIVERS AUTOMATICALLY
GIVEN YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR SO I PLEDGE FOR THE
EFFORT I THINK AND I THINK THIS
IS.
THE THE VALUABLE ROLE OF OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE SO I
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
A GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I SIXTY NINE I I ALSO SUPPORT
THE SPELLING AGREE.
MISTER CLAY WITH YOUR ASSESSMENT
THAT IT'S JUST THE KIND OF THING
THAT.
THE MOST CALIFORNIANS WOULD LIKE
US TO BE DOING AND I DO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING AND SHARING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK IT'S HARD TO ARGUE
AGAINST JUST WHAT SEEMS TO BE
KIND OF A FUNDAMENTAL ATTEMPT TO
JUST THREE STREAMLINING
RATIONALIZE.
REGULATIONS THAT ARE REALLY NOT
DOING ANYTHING PRODUCTIVE OTHER
THAN YOU KNOW KIND OF ADDING RED
TAPE ADDING.
UNNECESSARY LAYERS OF CONFUSION --
I THINK PERHAPS AS THIS MOVES
FOR THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO PARTNER
WITH WITH YOU ALL TO GET YOU. TO
PLACE THE BEING COMFORTABLE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT THE
THINGS YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
ARE THE THINGS THAT.
MR COOLEY IS IS REALLY TRYING.
TRYING TO DO WITH THE SPELL --
TO THANK YOU I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY SOUND
AND GOOD GOVERNMENT SO.
I'M WE ARE MAKING AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION TODAY THANKS FOR
WE THAT WE DO NEED TO PASS THAT
COMMITTEE ROLES IS THERE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECOND.
EXCELLENT CAN YOU PLEASE SAT.
CALL THE ROLL.
PRODUCTION FOR ADOPTION OF RULES.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA HI QUIRK SILVA AYE
SMITH.
SMITH BY.
GREAT AND FOR THE BILL THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY DISCUSSING I THINK
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
EXCELLENT ALRIGHT SECRETARY ON A
CALL THE ROLL NOT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS.
I PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA HI QUIRK SILVA ICE
MINT.
SMITH HI.
SO YOU'RE OUT OF THIS VERY NON
TO PREPARATIONS THANK YOU THE
CONCERN TIENEN.
AND THAT BEFORE WE HAVE OUR NEXT
AUTHOR COME UP WE'RE GONNA
QUICKLY VOTE ON THE ITEMS THAT
ARE ON THE CONSENT.
AGENDA.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND ON THAT
OKAY.
I SECRETARY OF CAN CALL THE ROLL
FOR THOSE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB.
469-518-80515.
THIRTY ONE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA HI QUIRK
SILVA AYE SMITH.
SMITH BY.
OKAY CONTENT CALENDAR IS DONE
MOVING TO FILE NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS.
AB TEN THIRTEEN MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR UNDERTOOK AN AUDIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
IS GRANT ISSUANCE PROCESS AND
AMONGST THEIR FINDINGS.
WAS THE FACT THAT THE D. O. R.
E. N..
HAD IN SEVERAL CASES ASSIGNED
EVALUATORS TO THOSE GRANTS THAT
HAD A DIRECT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BECAUSE THE EVALUATOR.
USED TO BE A MEMBER OF THE STAFF
OF THE AGENCY THAT WAS APPLYING
FOR THE GRAND SO THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED THAT WE ADOPTED
STATUTE A PROHIBITION AGAINST
THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR SO THIS
BILL AB.
TEN THIRTEEN IMPLEMENTS THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION IT SAYS
THAT STATE AGENCIES SHALL NOT
ASSIGN GRANT TODAY WAITERS TO
EVALUATE GRANTS THAT HAVE A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THE AYE THE A PLAYER FOR THE
GRANT.
BECAUSE THAT COULD CREATE THE
PERCEPTION OF BIAS WHICH IS
CORROSIVE TO A FREE DEMOCRACY.
AT THIS IS COMMON SENSE GOOD
GOVERNMENT LEGISLATION I WANT TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE BILL --
AMONGST THE POINTS OF THE
DISCUSSION IN THE ANALYSIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE LOOK AT
PERHAPS NOT A LIFETIME BAN BUT
SOME SOMETHING MORE LIMITED SO
THAT JUST HAVING SERVED ON STAFF
DOES NOT PROHIBIT YOU FOR THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE FOR BEING A
GRANT EVALUATOR AND I THINK.
THAT'S A REASONABLE ONE WE'RE TO
BE LOOKING AT THAT MOVING
FORWARD I MAY BE LOOKING AT FOR
SIMILAR SITUATIONS IN FEDERAL
LAW -- THAT WE COULD USE A AND
AND ADOPT FOR THIS PURPOSE.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAID.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THAT ON AS
WE KNOW SEASONED PROFESSIONALS
OFTEN LATER IN THEIR CAREER WHEN
THE MOST VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
THEY CAN MAKE IS TO DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR IN THE CHAIRS OF
FLEXIBILITY IN WORKING ON THAT
AND I SUPPORT.
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
RIGHT SECTARIAN A CALL THE WRONG.
THE MOTION IS A DO PASS
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE HI LACKEY LACKEY I AM
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH.
SMITH I RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RIGHT MOVING TO I MR COVER
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION
FREE BECAME AN ACT WOULD REQUIRE
STATE CONTRAST COMPRISE OF
FOREST RISK COMMODITIES LIKE
PALM OIL SOY.
CATTLE RUBBER APPALLED.
ENTERED A RENEWED ON OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TO CERTIFY THEIR
OPERATIONS AND THEIR SUPPLY
CHAINS ARE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION.
EVERY COMPANY CONTRACTED WITH
CALIFORNIA FOR SUCH COMMODITIES
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE IN
PLACE A NO DEFORESTATION NO P..
NO EXPLOITATION ALSO KNOWN AS
THE NDP POLICY.
AT A DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS
POLICY IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
FULLY AND IN GOOD FAITH.
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT CAUSE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AS WELL AS WIDE RANGING IMPACTS
ON BIODIVERSITY AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION
CREEP ACUMEN ACT WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO GLOBAL EFFORTS TO END
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION BY
ENSURING THAT ENTITIES CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO
NOT CONTRIBUTE TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION DIRECTLY.
OR THROUGH THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS.
AB BY SEVENTY TWO EXTENDS
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP THE PROTECTION
TROPICAL FORESTS AND SENDS A
CRUCIAL SIGNAL TO GLOBAL MARKETS
THAT ILLEGAL AND DESTRUCTIVE
COMMODITY DRIVEN DEFORESTATION.
WILL NO LONGER BE TOLERATED.
AB BY SEVENTY TWO IS NOT
DISSIMILAR TO WAYS TGS CERTIFIES
CONTRACTORS.
UP.
FROM NOT ENGAGING IN CERTAIN
BEHAVIORS IN THE BILL IS MODELED
AFTER AN EXISTING PROCUREMENT
BAN AGAINST CHILD LABOR.
THE STATE HAS HAD IN PRACTICE
FOR MANY YEARS.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL IS
CERTAINLY NOT INTENDED TO BE A
GOTCHA POLICY FOR INCIDENTAL
USES AND FACTOR IS LIABILITY
PROTECTION FOR CONTRACTORS THAT
UNKNOWINGLY USE FOR US WAS
COMMODITIES IN PARAGRAPH OF TWO
OF THE BILL.
THERE IS A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION ON STATE CONTRACTORS
IN RETURN FOR THE BUSINESS TO
TAKE REASONABLE STEPS THE
PRODUCT THEY'RE SOURCING NOT.
INCLUDE FOREST RISK COMMODITIES.
ALSO IN ORDER TO PROMOTE
GUIDANCE AND BEST PRACTICES.
AB BY SEVENTY TWO REQUIRES
DIGEST TO DEVELOP A DEPORTATION
FREE CODE OF CONDUCT THAT
INCLUDES A LIST OF POOREST RISK.
COMMODITIES AND GUIDANCE TO
CONTRACTORS IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
FOR US WAS COMMODITIES.
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND IS IS AS
IS OUR CUSTOMARY PRACTICE WERE
NOT A TIME TO BE OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE YOU WANT THE
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CREATE.
A PROGRAM THAT WORKS WITH THEM.
I WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS NICK SACK FROM
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION WILL BE INTRODUCING
DOUG NORTHERN REPRESENTING PENS
THE EARTH AND KATIE CLEARY ON
BEHALF OF PEACE FOR ANIMALS.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SACKETT DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR CO
SPONSOR SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ACTIONS TO AND TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION AND PROTECT
TROPICAL FORCE AS UNIQUE AND
IMPORTANT ECOSYSTEMS.
THAT PROVIDE HABITAT TO NEARLY
50% OF ALL SPECIES ON THE PLANET.
KLAY MOTHER MUCH OF THE PLANET'S.
MOST ICONIC AND TREASURED
WILDLIFE TROPICAL FORESTS ARE
ALSO CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF THE
EARTH WATER WHETHER AN OXYGEN
CYCLES.
IN FUNCTION AS A GLOBALLY
HOWEVER TROPICAL FORESTS ARE
GRAVELY THREATENED AN ESTIMATED
EIGHTEEN MILLION ACRES OF
TROPICAL FORESTS ARE LOST EVERY
YEAR DUE TO HUMAN ACTIVITIES.
AND TROPICAL DEFORESTATION IS
THE THIRD LEADING DRIVER OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ACCOUNTING FOR AS
MUCH AS 14% OF GLOBAL CO TWO
EMISSIONS.
THE THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION IS
INDUSTRIAL SCALE PRODUCTION OF
ALLIED AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES
KNOWN AS FORCE RISK COMMODITIES
SUCH AS PALM OIL SOY CATTLE.
RUBBER PAPER PULP AND TIMBER.
PRODUCTS CONTAINING THESE
COMMODITIES ARE WIDELY CONSUMED
INCLUDING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH ITS
GOVERNMENT PROCUREMENT.
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTS.
AS A SIGNATORY TO THE NEW YORK
DECLARATION ON FOREST.
CALIFORNIA SET A GOAL TO CUT
DEFORESTATION IN HALF BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND TO AND TO ENTIRELY BY.
TWENTY THIRTY IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG UNDERSTOOD
THE OBJECTIVE OF REDUCING
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION TO
CONTRIBUTE TOWARD THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS AS EXPRESSED IN
THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP IN THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE AND FORCE
TASK FORCE.
AB FIVE SEVEN TWO WOULD NOT ONLY
ADDRESS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT'S DIRECT CONTRIBUTION
TO TROPICAL DEFORESTATION A
SUBSTANTIAL MEASURE ON ITS OWN.
IT WOULD ALSO SEND A CRUCIAL
SIGNAL TO THE GLOBAL MARKET THE
DESTRUCTIVE COMMODITY DRIVEN
DEFORESTATION WILL NO LONGER BE
TOLERATED.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANT AB FIVE
SEVEN TWO WOULD START THE
CONVERSATION IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
HOW WE AS A STATE.
ARE NOT INADVERTENTLY
CONTRIBUTING TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION WITH ALL THE
ECOLOGICAL CLIMATE AND SOCIAL
DAMAGES THAT COME WITH IT.
WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND I GIVE THE MICROPHONE TO
THAT KNOWING THE FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
RESPECTED MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DOUG NORRLAND I
DIRECT THE ECONOMIC POLICY
PROGRAM.
AT FRIENDS OF THE EARTH U. S. --
FRIENDS HERE IT IS A
INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION OF
SEVENTY FIVE EFFECTIVE IN --
SEVENTY FIVE COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
INCLUDING MANY OF THE COUNTRIES --
THAT THIS BILL IS CONCERNED WITH
IN THE US WE HAVE ONE POINT.
SEVEN MILLION ACTIVE MEMBERS AND
WE WERE CREATED ACTUALLY HER
RIGHT HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD IN GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
SERIOUS COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
THE STATE HAS RESPONSIBILITY AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE OUR
PURCHASING POWER TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS.
OF TROPICAL DEFORESTATION.
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO IS THE MOST
DIRECT THE EASIEST AND THE
CHEAPEST WAY TO DO THIS.
BY REQUIRING THAT COMPANIES
PROVIDING FOR STRICT PRODUCTS TO
CALIFORNIA.
UNDERTAKE THOROUGH DUE DILIGENCE
IN THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ASKS
CONTRACTING ACTORS TO DO WHAT
THEY SHOULD DO.
AND WHAT MANY OF THEM ARE
ALREADY -- DOING AND COMMIT AND
ARE COMMITTED TO DO.
THAT IS TO TRACE THE COMMODITIES
THEY BUY BACK TO WHERE THEY COME
FROM.
AND TO AFFIRM THAT THESE
COMMODITIES ARE NOT PRODUCED AT
THE EXPENSE OF OUR LAST
REMAINING TROPICAL FORESTS OR
THE PEOPLE OR WILDLIFE.
UPON WHOM THESE FORESTS ARE HOME --
THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP CREATE
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. FOR
BUSINESS SO THAT THE BEST
COMPANY.
THE INCREASINGLY LARGE NUMBER OF
SUPPLIERS THAT HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED TO ELIMINATING
DEFORESTATION FROM THEIR SUPPLY
CHAINS WON'T FACE UNDUE
COMPETITION FROM THE LAGGARDS.
THE ONES WHO UP UNTIL NOW.
REFUSED TO FOLLOW BEST
INTERNATIONAL PRACTICES HUMAN
RIGHTS NORMS AND SUSTAINABLE
SOURCING PRINCIPLES.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA'S BEST CHANCE
TO A PLAYER GREAT STATES CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP TO THE SUPPLY CHAINS.
OF THE MANY MULTINATIONAL
COMPANIES ON WHO MORE
CONSUMPTION DEPENDS.
IF WE CARE ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
OUR STATES CUMPLIR CONSUMPTION.
HAS ON THE REST OF THE WORLD AB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO IS THE LEAST WE
CAN DO I THANK YOU AND WE WOULD
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT WITH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US MADAM
CHAIR -- MY NAME IS KATIE CLEARY
AND THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
WORLD ANIMAL NEWS AND PEACE FOR
ANIMALS OUT OF LOS ANGELES --
AND I'M ALSO THE BOARD MEMBER OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION --
FOR A FEW YEARS FOR A FEW YEARS
NOW AND WORKING ON MY SECOND
DOCUMENTARY CALLED WE ARE ONE
AND IT'S HAS TO DO WITH THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN -- ANIMALS
ENDANGERED SPECIES ON OUR PLANET
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
AND SO THIS PAST FOLLOWS IN
SUMATRAN BORNEO FILMING AND I
SAW SOME OF THE MOST HORRIFIC
THINGS I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE --
DEFORESTED LAND -- FOR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF MILES --
ILLEGALLY DEFORESTED ACTUALLY --
BURNED TO THE GROUND -- WE
RESCUED ENTERING A TANK THAT WAS
FOUR MONTHS PREGNANT FROM A PALM
OIL PLANTATION ACTUALLY
SURROUNDED.
BY OTHER PALMA PLANTATIONS AND
DIED SHE WAS SHOT -- MOST DURING
IT HANGS ARE SHOT TO SHOT WITH A
TWENTY TWO BILLION IN OUR SIDE --
ABOUT 90% OF RAINY TANKS ARE
SHOT -- BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONSIDERED PASSED BY THE PALM
OIL INDUSTRY AND OTHER
INDUSTRIES AS WELL -- IT TOOK AN
HOUR TO SEDATE HER -- WE
EVENTUALLY WERE ABLE -- TO YOU
KNOW CATCHER IN AND THAT'S AND
WE FOUND OUT SHE WAS PREGNANT AT
THAT TIME IT WAS TOGETHER WITH
HEARING TING INFORMATION CENTER.
AND I THINK THAT IF MOST PEOPLE
SAW THIS FOOTAGE AND REALIZE
THAT. FOR THE 500-002-60000
RINGGIT HANGS ARE THE ONLY ONES
REMAINING IN THE WILD -- OF
WHICH MOST OF THEM ARE REMAIN IN
SUMATRA AND BORNEO AND VERY FEW
AND IN JAVA ON THE ISLAND OF
JAVA -- BUT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING -- HERE IS THAT --
THERE'S THERE'S A DEMAND AND THE
DEMAND WE DON'T KNOW -- IS --
THE RIGHT DEMAND SEWED DO WE
REALLY PUT A PRICE ON THE
EXTINCTION OF THE SPEECH IS NOT
ONLY THE SPECIES BUT THERE'S
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED SUMATRAN
TIGERS LEFT IN THE WILD.
YOU CAN WE WERE WE SPENT ABOUT
TWO WEEKS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RAINFOREST WE COULDN'T SEE
WITHIN SEE -- ONE THEY'RE SO
RARE NOT ONLY THAT -- THE THE
JOB AND RIGHT NOW.
WE THINK THERE'S ONLY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY REMAINING AND IT'S
DUE TO DEFORESTATION AND AND
LACK OF HABITAT AND THE
CORRIDORS -- CONNECTING THEM ARE
THE ONLY THING LEFT TO BE ABLE
TO DIVERSIFY -- THEIR DNA -- TO
SAVE THEIR SPECIES FROM
EXTINCTION SO WE'RE TALKING
POSSIBLY -- THE NEXT TEN YEARS
WE MIGHT LOSE ALL THE SPEECHES
IN INDONESIA TO EXTINCTION IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING QUICKLY AND
CALIFORNIA HAS THE ABILITY -- TO
REALLY PUT A POLICY IN PLACE TO
PROTECT OUR FORESTS OF WHICH WE
GAME 30% OF OUR OXYGEN OF COURSE
THE REST 70% -- YOU KNOW COMES
FROM THE OCEAN -- AND OF COURSE --
YOU KNOW BEING A VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS AND I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO -- YOU
KNOW WE SHARE THE PLANET WITH
UPWARDS OF EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION SPECIES THAT WE KNOW OF
IN THE RAIN FOREST -- HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WE MIGHT NOT KNOW
ABOUT BECAUSE IT'S BEING
DESTROYED SO I REALLY ENCOURAGE
YOU -- IF IF I CAN SHOW YOU --
THE FOOTAGE THAT WE TOOK IT IS
SOME OF THE MOST POWERFUL
FOOTAGE OF EVER SEEN AND IT WAS
THE HARDEST THING TO DO.
BEING IN THAT RAIN FOREST -- AND
A HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREE WEATHER
LITERALLY -- SAVING THIS THIS
FEMALE RANG A TANG AND WE
RELOCATED HER SUCCESSFULLY BUT
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE DESTRUCTION
OF THE RAIN FOREST -- THAT THIS
IS HAPPENING AND SHOULDN'T BE
HAPPENING -- THEIR THEIR CALL
DURING ITS HANG THEY MEAN PERSON
OF THE RAIN FOREST -- IN
INDONESIAN SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AND AGAIN COULD WE REALLY
PUT A PRICE ON EXTINCTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AS A MODERATE SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION IN LOS ANGELES IN
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TREES A BURKE VERGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LISA CARLIN SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION AND JANE AND CHAIN
NEWS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRIAN -- WIKI FOR THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND STRONG
ANY WITNESSES AN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE I MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP YES
THE AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE THE WITNESSES
WHO HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY.
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF REALLY
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE ON THIS
ISSUE -- AND I WOULD JUST LIKE.
TO CLOSE BY SAYING THAT IT WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO DO MORE AS
A PLANET -- ALTHOUGH SOMETIMES
CALIFORNIA MAY BE ON THE IN
TERMS OF THE NATIONAL SCENE
FEELS LIKE ONE ISLAND BUT WE'RE
NOT AN ISLAND -- EVERYTHING WE
DO IMPACTS OTHERS AND IF WE
DON'T PROTECT THESE FOR US ALL
THE WORK WE'RE DOING -- AND ON
CLIMATE CHANGE I'M GONNA ASK US
EMISSIONS -- BUT REALLY.
DOESN'T AMOUNT TO MUCH UNLESS
WERE REALLY THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO PROTECT THE
HABITATS FOR INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES FOR OUR PLANET AND
FOR THESE ANIMALS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
JACK THREE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS LINE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH.
SMITH I IF YOU WERE OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF
BEN SAID THAT OTHER MEMBERS MATT
ON THE CONVENTION.
THANK YOU REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK GOODNESS.
OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
MISTER CHIU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO ADDRESS
DELAYS IN PAYMENT TO CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTORS FOR
EXTRA WORK THAT HAS BEEN
PERFORMED.
THE BILL'S VERY SIMPLE IT WOULD
ELIMINATE THE SUNSET DATE FROM A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LAW THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED THAT
CLOSED A LOOPHOLE IN PROP
PAYMENT LAW.
WHEN IT COMES TO HOW TO DECIDE
HOW TO RESOLVE DISPUTES ARE IN
THE CLAIMS PROCESS -- THAT HAS.
OFTENTIMES HAPPEN WHEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE NOT HAD MUCH OF AN
INCENTIVE TO PAY CONTRACTORS AND
A TIMELY MANNER.
WHILE PUBLIC COUNTRY CODE
PROVIDES PROMPT PAYMENT
REQUIREMENTS IN MANY OTHER AREAS
OF THE CONSTRUCTION PAYMENT
PROCESS WITHOUT THE PROCESS OF
THE PREVIOUS BILL IMPLEMENTED
WITHIN THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE.
IT DOES NOT DO SO FOR EXTRA WORK
PERFORMED EVEN WHEN THAT WORK
WAS REQUESTED BY THE AGENCY AND
PERFORMED IN GOOD FAITH.
THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
PAIN CONTRACTORS ON TIME BY
ELIMINATED THE SUNSET DATE
CONTRACTORS WHO BID AND PERFORM
FOR THIS VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WORK FOR STATE.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEY'LL GET PAID FOR
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE AND WITH
THAT I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORTERS
AND WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO A
BERNACCHI.
WHO IS REPRESENTING OUR SPONSORS?
AB MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- GOOD
MORNING EDDIE BERNACCHI ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND UNITED
CONTRACTORS -- THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL I WANT TO THANK --
FIRST AND FOREMOST THIS AND
REMEMBER CHIU FOR HIS WORK IN
THIS AREA OVER THE YEARS --
ADDRESSING -- DISPUTED PAYMENTS
IN THE AREAS OF CHANGE ORDERS
AND EXTRA WORK OUTSIDE OF THE
ORIGINAL CONTRACT HAS BEEN -- A
MAJOR ISSUE WHEN THE BIGGEST
ISSUES FOR A CONTRACTORS --
STATEWIDE -- IN THIS LIMITED
NECK THE JOB EXPLAINING -- THE
NEED FOR THE POLICY I WOULD ONLY
ADD THAT WHILE THERE'S NO METRIC
TO DEMONSTRATE HOW MANY TIMES
THIS POLICY HAS BEEN -- UTILIZED --
IN THE REAL WORLD -- YOU KNOW IT
ANECDOTALLY OUR CONTRACTORS HAVE.
GOTTEN BACK TO ME THAT BECAUSE
OF ITS EXISTENCE IN THE ABILITY
UNDER THE PROCESS FOR THE
CONTACTED TO INITIATE.
THE POLIC -- THAT IS EXTRA
EVENT EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF DISPUTES
AND LITIGATION IN THIS AREA --
SO WITH THAT I WOULD TO STATES
INCREDIBLY PORT AND PORT POLICY
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY --
THE FACT THAT WE ARE ABLE TO GET
TO A COMPROMISE WITH PUBLIC
AGENCIES ON THE ORIGINAL BILL
THAT THEY WERE COMFORTABLE WITH --
AND THAT CONTRACTORS COULD
SUPPORT AT THE DEMONSTRATES THAT
IS A A A SOUND POLICY.
AND WE WERE -- JUROR -- I VOTE
ON THE ELIMINATION OF THE SUNSET.
THE BILL SECOND.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TAUGHT
BLOOM STEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MIKE
MONACAN ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE
PEPPERIDGE COUNCIL.
AND WESTERN STATES COUNTS ON
SHEET METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE.
THE COMMITTEE FOR MY LETTER NOT
GETTING HERE IN TIME TO MAKE THE
ANALYSIS BUT WHEN CONTRACTORS
AREN'T PAID THEY CAN'T MAKE
PAYMENTS TO OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
FIND HELPFUL HEALTH AND WELFARE
FUNDS FOR EVERY MEMBERS SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE SUPPORT
TODAY SO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATE ON YOU DURING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LAYPERSON'S SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RIGHT BEAR
WITH THE WESTERN LINE
CONSTRUCTORS IN THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY CREDIT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES AN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT THIS ENJOYS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WHICH LIKE.
TO I WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD TO THE
ROTH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH.
SMITH HI.
RIGHT NOT CONCLUDES OUR UP FIRST.
I ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW MEETING OF
THE YEAR -- WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES AND
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ON THANK YOU
.
IF YOU PLEASE AS SECRETARY CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
A. B. FOUR FIFTY SIX PATTERSON
PATTERSON I A. B. FIVE SEVENTY
TWO PATTERSON [inaudible]
PERSON NOW
.
AT THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE IN TWO
WEEKS